die korona krise ist auch eine
wirtschaftskrise wie wir sie seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg nicht erlebt haben
ökonomen fordern jetzt auf wachstum zu
setzen auch auf kosten des klimas meyer
göbel die bei mir zu gast ist sagt das
ist der falsche weg warum wollen sie
gerade jetzt umsteuern
also erstens wissen wir natürlich wenn
wir weiter den klimawandel fröhlich
drauf zu laufen werden wir noch ganz
andere krisen bekommen als jetzt corona
das heißt das ist eine kostenfrage die
sollten wir nicht mit rein nehmen in die
rechnung und das andere wir können ja
auch ganz andere dinge nämlich ein umbau
unserer wirtschaft in richtung
klimaneutralität beispielsweise jetzt
mit dem vielen öffentlichen geld
finanzieren
das wäre meine priorität es geht um die
verknüpfung von ökonomie und ökologie
und sie beginnen mit einem bild was
vielleicht viele menschen kennen ein
bild von apollo 8 da sieht man den preis
das heißt dass ausgehend quasi der erde
als die astronauten bei apollo 8 hinter
dem mond die erde erblicken
das ist ein ganz berühmtes bild geworden
warum haben sie das genommen
im grunde genommen geht es ja die
hauptbotschaft dass es um ein
weiterdenken gehen also ganz
aufklärerische liberale agenda zu sagen
wenn sich die rahmenbedingungen so sehr
verändert haben dann sollten wir auch
die konzepte neu denken und die analogie
die wir da machen ist dass die ideen von
endlosen wachstum also dass menschen
immer mehr einfach aus dem planeten
rausnehmen können weil der planet endlos
sheen war im 17 18 19 jahrhundert noch
eine rationale geschichte weil wir
einfach nicht mal wussten aber da ist
irgendwann tatsächlich ende
wir haben sehr kolonialistisch erst mal
zugegriffen auf die anderen ressourcen
und jetzt sagt uns die wissenschaft auch
noch obst ihr kippt die ökosysteme aus
der balance die eigentlich das wieder
aufbauen dieser ressourcen ermöglichen
und das ist ja eine neue realität dass
wir viele menschen haben die sehr stark
in ihrem konsumniveau es dass aus dem
kleinen in anspruch nehmen was im
verhältnis zu einem sehr großen leeren
planet wenig menschen viel natur wenig
ökonomische aktivität eine komplett neue
realität darstellt und das hat dieses
bild so deutlich gemacht und ist auch in
dem brundtland bericht denn unser 87 ja
schon gesagt hat
wir müssen jetzt wirklich sehr anders
wirtschaften damit wir umwelt und
soziales tatsächlich zusammen bekommen
dass das eine ganz neue realität ist die
eigentlich einen hinterfragen des
menschenbildes mit sich bringen sollte
also eine ähnliche revolution im denken
und im dinge betrachten wie gut die
kopernikanische revolution so gemerkt
haben vielleicht dreht sich die sonne
nicht um uns sondern die erde um die
sonne kann man wieder als eine kränkung
finden dass wir noch ein weniger wichtig
sind weil wenn wir das mit dem ökosystem
nicht verstehen sind wir vielleicht die
spezies die als nächstes geht irgendwann
aber man kann auch ist einem tollen
auftrag begreifen und sagen das ist doch
ein fantastisches wunderschönes heimat
planet erde aber eben ein raumschiff
erde das hat nun mal grenzen und dann
sollten wir die auch akzeptieren und
sagen wie kann man sich längerfristig
einreise dieser dieses berühmte buch die
grenzen des wachstums in den 70er jahren
war es ja damals an ein pochen buch war
hat man in den 70er jahren das
vorhersehen können was wir was sie jetzt
vor allen dingen auch beschreiben also
das problem des ressourcenverbrauchs in
so einer größenordnung über so eine
langfristigkeit eine modellhaft ich kite
zu berechnen die sagt wir werden an
probleme bekommen das ökologisch die
zerstörung zu groß wird wenn wir weiter
ressourcen aus dem boden holen und das
ist der weitere wichtige punkt es ging
um einen materiellen durchsatz der bbs
da echt egal das sind alles wirklich
preis erfindungen und es ging darum zu
verstehen dass die ökologischen kosten
ja nicht sind das öl beispielsweise im
boden drin zu lassen sondern die
begrenzte ressource ist die atmosphäre
sprich die regenerativen ökosystem und
das geht uns bei den werden zum beispiel
auch wir haben jetzt kein problem mit
seltenen erden das problem liegt darin
wenn wir da überall dran kommen wollen
dann müsste fast die ganze oberfläche
irgendwann platt machen dh dann aber
leider biodiversität wälder weg wasser
zyklen weg war dass daraus pressen ist
unter den fans also bei den passanten
sieht man das ja schon der aufwand die
kosten um den energieträger rauszuholen
oder das erz rauszuholen was wir dann
brauchen in unserer ökonomie werden so
groß dass es einfach ein und
ökonomisches wachstum ist und das ist
das ganze plädoyer
wir sind mitten in ihrem buch wie sie
das gerade beschreiben gebe noch ein
kleines stück zurück und gehen wir noch
mal an die situation heran die wir im
augenblick erleben
wir uns mal die deutsche autoindustrie
anschauen sie haben ja gerade auch von
den seltenen erden gesprochen wir reden
auch über elektroautos über
unterstützung für die autoindustrie
dann haben wir doch genau diesen dieses
dilemma dieses problem was sich stellt
wenn ich auf der einen seite weiß ich
muss diese wirtschaft jetzt stützen ich
muss etwas für die autoindustrie tun
aber auf der anderen seite ja auch weiß
ich muss es hier allein wegen der
arbeitsplätze schon tun unterstütze aber
im zweifelsfall einen neuen konsum der
vielleicht gar nicht nötig ist weil man
auto drei jahre alt ist warum soll ich
dann neues kaufen sind wir nicht genau
in diesem dilemma drin
also wir nennen das ja strukturwandel
den harz aber auch schon immer gegeben
und manchmal wird es gefeiert wenn man
diese später an anderen volk die
kreative zerstörung war ja ein teil des
fortschritts
aber in dem moment wo die kreative
zerstörung stattfindet werden diejenigen
die sich als der seite wähnen die
verlieren natürlich dagegen wehren und
das wichtige ist deshalb aus meiner
perspektive immer die
volkswirtschaftliche perspektive
einzunehmen oder die
gesamtgesellschaftliche weil wir sind ja
alle mehr als nur arbeitnehmerinnen in
einem bestimmten unternehmen
wir können auch noch mal ein anderes
unternehmen gründen wenn dieses eben den
beitrag heute nicht mehr leistet ich
kann meine produktpalette umbauen ich
kann ja gucken wie ich unternehmerisches
handeln einer sich verändernden realität
anpassen
und genau dafür haben wir in deutschland
ja nun auch sozialsysteme also dass
niemand auf die straße fällt und ich
finde es schon wichtig zu unterscheiden
oder zu bemerken wieder unterschieden
wird die künstler und die ganzen
kreativen bei denen wird gesagt ja dann
noch doch alg1 doch jetzt kein problem
haben doch ein sozialer
sicherungssysteme
aber wenn es um den job in der
autoindustrie geht wird geschrien dass
das eeg als gäbe ist es nicht dabei ist
wahrscheinlich das was monatlich auf dem
konto ankommt bei denen die aus der
industrie gekommen sind deutlich höher
als bei denen die vorher schon prekären
job gemacht haben weil die
vergütungsstrukturen in den sozialen und
künstlerischen sektoren eh schon
ziemlich nach unten am prekariat waren
und ich will das auch gar nicht werden
ich möchte darauf aufmerksam machen dass
wieder mit unterschiedlichem maß messen
und insgesamt und sie als
volkswirtschaft können müssen übergangs
prozesse zu gestalten und dafür braucht
es aber prozesse und das ist ja das ist
ein stück weit fehlt dann ist es im
zweifelsfall auch eine frage der
fürsprecher für branchen
sie sind im beirat der bundesregierung
balle umweltveränderungen beschäftigen
sich also mit dem was in zukunft auch
passieren könnte bleiben wir noch mal
gerade bei der autoindustrie die ja auch
ein großes klimaprobleme hat jetzt hat
die bundesregierung sich entschieden und
hat gesagt wir wollen e autos fördern
aber wir wollen nicht die alten
verbrenner weiter fördern ist das denn
eine entscheidung aus ihrer sicht aus
ökologischer sicht die sinnvoll und
gleichzeitig ökonomisch ist ja klar
also ich finde das auch unehrlich wenn
irgendjemand behauptet aus dem
autokonzern dass die e-mobilität
aufzuhalten sei und deshalb ist es ein
raid addieren von etwas von dem man weiß
dass es schon kommt und dann kann ich
mir auch fragen wie sollte ich nicht
jetzt lieber im grunde genommen
vielleicht kurzarbeitergeld weiter
auszahlen erstmal für die person und
sagen sie haben jetzt ein recht auf
weiterbildung ein recht auf umschulung
wir gucken mal was in dem cluster
beendet wegen um wolfsburg herum
eventuell an alternativen dingen für
ladestationen oder andere formen der
erneuerbaren energien auch hergestellt
werden könnte wir haben ja in der korona
krise schon gesehen dass auf einmal
produktionsstätten auch masken oder
andere sachen produzieren konnten
und das heißt diese dass man mit dem
unternehmertum einfach auch zu
antizipieren was sind die zukünftigen
märkte was sind die zukünftigen jobs und
menschen mitzunehmen und ihnen die
übergänge leichter zu machen oder sie
auch mal zu fragen
das vergessen wir auch immer also im
februar gab es erst große um fragen wie
viele menschen eigentlich richtig lust
hätten noch mal was ganz anderes zu
machen
aber wenn dann das natürlich so anfühlt
als würde ich transformiert und als
würde ich aussortiert dann ist das
natürlich was das angst macht und wenn
ich aber gleichzeitig viel mehr
involviert werde und gefragt werden okay
was wäre denn etwas das dich noch mal
interessiert und das meine ich mit den
prozessen da gibt es eine ganze
forschung dazu die sich das transition
nennt und die haben im kohle bereich
gehabt da gibt es auf der eu in den
green deal auch einen fördertopf dafür
wirklich ganz transition governance also
wie organisiere ich diese prozesse dass
die menschen die betroffen sind mit
involviert werden in der gestaltung der
übergänge
das haben wir zu wenig bisher gemacht
jetzt kann ich mir vorstellen auf
europäischer ebene gibt es konzepte auch
eine realistische chance so etwas
umzusetzen aber schauen wir mal auf eine
situation während der korona krise
da waren die fabrikhallen in bangladesch
leer
sie haben kritisiert in dem buch dass
die menschen in deutschland zum beispiel
billig kleidung kaufen zum teil wird die
verfeuert weil man gar nicht weiß was
man mit der machen soll
aber wir finanzieren arbeiterinnen etwa
in bangladesch damit und während der
korona krise wurde kann textil verkauft
und die sachsen waren lehrer die haben
kein geld mehr verdient da haben wir ja
auch eine verantwortung für ja wir haben
vor allem die verantwortung dafür dass
die strukturen so geworden sind wie sie
jetzt sind
dass nämlich viele länder sehr abhängig
sind von ihrem export das war ja eine
art der globalisierung die
globalisierung gedacht wurde und dann
eben auch von den institutionen weltbank
oder internationaler währungsfonds durch
kreditvergabe und konditionen wie sich
in diesen ländern eben ein
strukturwandel vollziehe vollziehen
sollte in anderen ländern fällt uns der
leichter haben wir auch innerhalb der
europäischen jugend schon irgendwann
wahrgenommen und dann sind dadurch eben
sehr weltmarkt abhängige system im
grunde genommen entstanden und da gibt
es schon länger von den vereinten
nationen von der abteilung die sich mit
internationale handel und arbeitsteilung
beschäftigt die studien entstanden die
gezeigt haben wie unheimlich verletzlich
dass dann diese volkswirtschaften macht
und das heißt kann im endeffekt auch
daher sagen wenn jetzt über residenz
sprechen und über wertschöpfungsketten
die genau weniger durch ganzfeld ich
könnte würde ich sagen dass nicht in dem
moment wo ein exportstopp stattfindet
eine ganze branche zusammenbricht kann
ich natürlich auch wieder übergangs
programme überlegen die durch den iwf
auch kofinanziert werden könnten durch
die weltbank die genau dort in denen
dann auch wieder eine regionalisierung
deine binnennachfrage würden wir das
jetzt nennen mit sich bringt und
typischerweise hab ich dann auch eine
aufwärtsspirale zwischen besseren löhnen
weil dann entsteht höhere kaufkraft und
damit ist es unternehmen wiederum
interessant weil sie dann natürlich
andere produkte absetzen können das
heißt es hat tatsächlich auch
entwicklungs impetus wenn man ein stück
weit wenigstens wieder regionalisiert
auf braucht die übergangsphase aber so
eine brennen glas situation hatten wir
jetzt beim fleischskandal für bei
turniers da sehen wir dass die
abhängigkeit der arbeiter extrem hoch
ist weil sie in ihrer osteuropäischen
familien das geld
in keiner weise einbringen müssen und
dann auch unter prekären verhältnissen
bereit sind zu arbeiten das verschafft
zwar dem deutschen der deutschen firma
milliarden-gewinne finanziert aber hier
auf der anderen seite auch die familien
in rumänien bulgarien wo auch immer wie
löst man diesen konflikt auf ja ich kann
es sind ja dynamiken dynamische
entwicklungen und ich kann entweder wir
nennen das dann positive feedback
schleife das heißt darüber nicht
normativ positiv oder negativ dass heißt
erstmal beschleunigen
das heißt ich kann sagen wir müssen das
so machen weil immerhin geht es dann
besser oder ich kann natürlich auch
überlegen
das ist für uns ja nun auch eine
abwärtsspirale also wenn das
arbeitskonditionen sind die wir in
diesem land akzeptieren wollen dann
frage ich mich was da richtig sind also
entweder entscheide ich mich dann
vernünftige arbeitsplätze anzubieten für
die menschen aus osteuropa aber nicht
unsere eigenen standards wirklich
komplett über den jordan zu schweißen
und dann natürlich davon zu profitieren
in dem ausmaß wie sie es beschrieben
haben also dann wünsche ich mir die
integrität dann sollen die menschen die
nicht in deutschland wohnen bitte auch
in ähnliche wenn sie sich hier verdienen
auch eine ähnliche grundlage für ihre
tätigkeit eben vorfinden
das wäre so das eine was ich diesen
argumenten gerne entgegen stellen würde
und das andere ist natürlich zu
überlegen ja wir haben mit der
europäischen union auftrag der kohäsion
sprich wir wollen ja lebensstandards
angleichen und dann schaue ich natürlich
was in kaufkraftparitäten die sind auch
unterschiedlich deshalb ganz die
gleichen löhne kann ich ja auch im
grunde genommen nicht dort einfordern
wenn da die miete was ganz anderes als
hier
aber wie schaffen wir inhalt insgesamt
lebensstandards ein stückweit
anzugleichen und welche investitionen
braucht es vielleicht da eben auch vor
ort also man kann so versuchen die
aufwärtsspirale zu suchen oder man kann
sich in eine abwärtsspirale ergeben
und das ist ganz viel politische
entscheidung und politischer wille
warum ist bei ihnen das engagement für
diese durchdringung von ökonomischer
welt und ökologie und ökonomie so
ausgeprägt ist das ein resultat ihrer
erziehung ihrer kindheit
ich habe geschrieben sind quasi als
hippie mädchen oder in einer art happy
familie groß geworden zumindest was die
nachbarn in dem dorf
seine metern wir hören doch erst recht
schaffen na also im prinzip wir haben
eine 68er generation die uns groß
gezogen hat und es gab viele
überlegungen wie man dinge anders machen
kann und eine dazu die dazu gehörte war
natürlich sich der ökologischen frage
auch zu widmen also bei den ärzten
ging's über die atomkraft weil sie
einfach wissen was das mit menschlichen
körpern tun kann wenn es da zu unfällen
kommt aber es ging dann eben auch
breiter und dieser zusammenhang zwischen
sozialer ökologischer stark und beim
klimawandel auch und als ich angefangen
habe ökonomisch nachzudenken und zu
versuchen zu erschließen wieso die
ökonomie so wenig rücksicht nimmt auf
die umwelt weil das ist ja der befund
ist ja da dann ist mir eben aufgefallen
wie wenig natur in den ganzen
ökonomischen modellen und erzählungen
über vorkommen so dass wir eben immer
noch wachstum messen obwohl wir eine
radikale schöpfung machen also wir haben
einen fantastischen bioreaktor geerbt
der 150 milliarden pro jahr allein die
bestäubung übernimmt wenn wir das selber
kreieren müssten würde uns das so viel
kosten und müssten roboter bienen oder
andere alternativen selber erfinden das
heißt wir müssten technologisch und
dadurch rusel mit investitionen und
kosten dann wären die hoch anfällig
anstatt zu sagen das funktioniert wieder
einzulassen jetzt einfach mal in ruhe
beschützen das jetzt mal und bezahlen
vielleicht dafür dass sich auch menschen
darum kümmern dürfen das blühstreifen
das biodiversität etz reihen unserer
landwirtschaft weniger pestizide dass
die insekten einfach erhalten werden und
das ist ja genau das wir haben eine
wahnsinnige wertschöpfung die uns die
natur einfach schenkt und ein
weitgehender teil der ökonomischen
bilanzen ist dazu völlig blind sondern
im zweifel kann ich geld damit verdienen
wenn ich nach einem großen unfall mit öl
etc
daneben das uvek kratzen muss weil
jemand bezahlt werden muss das messen
wir das wachstum aber ist das dann nicht
eher ein psychologisches problem das
heißt sie beschreiben ja den menschen
als an naturwesen der lebt in der natur
und jetzt reden wir schon von einer
umwelt also einer naturwelt die um uns
herum ist ist dann psychologie nicht
psychologisch etwas schiefgelaufen genau
und das wäre ja dieses update des
menschlichen selbstverständnis und da
hat uns jetzt corona auch sehr geholfen
so sind ziemlich deutlich wider
biologische riesen geworden weil wir
alle wie ihren trägerinnen waren und im
prinzip ist es auch übergesprungen aus
der natur auf uns menschen und wir haben
gemerkt wenn die
nahrungsmittelversorgung nachlässt das
ist das was uns als erstes nahe geht
also in krisen momenten mehr hatten wir
ja sehr schnell was wir wirklich
brauchen und dann kamen die frank den
systemrelevanten jobs also es war ja
eigentlich ein wunderbares durchbrechen
also wunderbar es natürlich ein
schlimmer begriffen im kontext aber ein
durchbrechen der routinen die uns auch
so blind haben werden lassen zu dem was
wirklich wichtig ist und was wir
kontinuierlich erodieren lassen
in der art und weise wird gewohnt sind
eben zu arbeiten und zu produzieren und
dieses korrigieren kann ja gleichzeitig
nur zwei sinnvolle wachstumsagenda
werden wenn wir sagen wir möchten die
ökosysteme wieder wachsen lassen so dass
sie sicher sind wir möchten eben
dekarbonisierung damit die aktie stabil
bleiben kann
wir möchten wieder mehr menschen im
pflege- und bildungsbereich beschäftigen
können damit sich die versorgung also
wieder anwächst die
versorgungssicherheit auf dem ganz
sozialen bereich das heißt wenn wir
anfangen zu sagen was wir gerne möchten
was entsteht in einer gesellschaft was
wachsen soll und was dafür schrumpfen
muss dann können wir die ökonomische
instrumente die investitionen die
bilanzen und im zweifel dann eben auch
das was hinter dem bwp steckt wieder mit
dem übereinstimmen oder aber einen
bringen was wir gerne hätten was
entstehen soll unserer gesellschaft und
das ist doch eigentlich eine total tolle
aufgabe da müsste sich die ökonomie
jetzt aber hinsetzen und sagen wir
müssen wir eigentlich überall
korrigieren an welchen bilanzen an
welchen indikatoren und so aber sind sie
sicher dass jemand in einem
entwicklungsland sagt ja ich denke da
mal gerne mit sind sie sicher dass
jemand der in einem solchen land lebt
und arm ist und eigentlich nicht weiß
wie er den nächsten und übernächsten tag
finanzieren soll für die familie sich
diesem gedanken nähern kann also ist da
nicht die diskrepanz zwischen unserer
diskussion über so etwas in der ersten
welt und der lage in der dritten welt
und der menschen die in armut leben
nicht eine riesige diskrepanz die wir
nicht auffüllen können in der
lebensrealität von wirklich an menschen
die immer noch sehr von der
subsistenzwirtschaft dem was die natur
ihnen
mit stellt ist die verbindung zwischen
sozialen und ökologischen einfach
evident jeden tag da wenn die dürre das
zerstört was mein kleiner
quadratmeterzahl war von der ich mich
ernährt habe dann ist ende und ich habe
kein sozialsystem das heißt es geht eher
darum dort da ist da fehlt das
bewusstsein gar nicht sondern es fehlt
vielleicht die informationen wie kann
ich mich klima resident umstellen in der
art wie ich das land bewirtschaftet und
es fehlt natürlich die finanzielle
unterstützung dann auch entsprechend
tätig werden zu können aber da gibt es
unheimlich viele programme wie wir da
zum beispiel big data und informationen
und mobiltelefone et cetera so benutzen
können dass wir im grunde genommen die
menschen die sehr gut wissen was
passiert wenn das ökologische ihnen
unter den füßen wegbricht so zu
befähigen das weiter zu erhalten uns an
veränderungen aus dem klimabereich
anzupassen deshalb ich finde das ganz
falsch aus der perspektive zu schauen
sondern es geht wirklich einfach darum
zu verhindern dass den menschen nichts
anderes übrig bleibt als sachen
abzubrennen weil wir gar nicht anders
sich ernähren können das hat immer wenn
eine treibende kraft die aus einer ja
einer mangelerscheinung auf der
alternativen seite entsteht und
überhaupt nicht aus dem dass das dort
nicht vermittelbar wäre oder nicht
unwichtig war bei denen bei denen es auf
den nägeln brennt ist ja auch die
ökologische situation im zweifel ein
sehr viel schlechter als bei uns wir
haben ja das große glück wie auch immer
dass wir in regionen leben bei denen die
schwierigkeiten der umwelt noch nicht
ganz so augenfällig sind wie etwa in
ländern wo die ökologische lage sehr
sehr brenzlig ist und schwierig ist wie
kriegt man denn da einen ausgleich wir
haben keine weltregierung also wer soll
im prinzip vorgeben wie wir diesen weg
beschreiten sollen
naja vorgeben also im prinzip braucht es
bestimmte richtungen die wir versuchen
aus der wissenschaft anzubieten und wir
haben ja auch bestimmte globale
vereinbarungen wie jetzt die jahre hajo
und paris hat nicht wirklich
funktioniert das schreiben sie auch in
dem buch also das ist nur nette
vereinbarung aber wenn wir zum beispiel
auf die messwerte sehen der der
emissionen dann hat das nicht wirklich
viel ausgemacht
gut wir haben die möglichkeit einmal
soll es natürlich durch internationale
zusammenarbeit
dafür zu sorgen dass dort in ländern wo
noch viel infrastruktur beispielsweise
entsteht oder ein energiesystem erst
noch aufgebaut werden muss dass nicht
der weg durch die kohle losgelaufen wird
jetzt haben ja gerade ein zuwachs von 38
prozent investitionen oder subventionen
für fossile energien gehabt das ist
natürlich eine ziemliche entwicklung die
sollte man politischen entscheid oder
eben auch zunehmend den finanzmärkten
versuchen zu korrigieren weil eigentlich
also direkt rein ökonomisch betrachtet
inzwischen die erneuerbaren im vorteil
werden aber wenn wir weiter
subventionieren können wir den die
transformation natürlich aufhalten und
die marktkräfte hindern
das wäre hat eins das man wirklich sagt
das energiesystem muss erneuerbar sein
das zweite ist wirklich sagen wir
brauchen regenerativen umgang mit land
wir versuchen biodiversität nahrung
energieversorgung und wohnraum im grunde
genommen auf den quadratmeter besser
wieder zu vereinen und da sind dann eben
andere formen nicht die grüne revolution
das war keine grüne revolution seine
braune revolution war unheimlich
energieintensiv wir brauchen immer diese
brauchen immer große maschinen
angefangen haben eben die landflächen zu
beackern und dann haben wir ertrag
gemessen in der tonne reis aber ein
ertrag von einem quadratmeter land hat
eben auch wasserspeicher co2 speicher
hat biodiversität also wenn wir anfangen
das alles wieder einzupreisen und das
sind die globalen gemeingüter das heißt
wir sind ja abhängig davon dass in den
ländern mit einer ganz ressourcen arm in
deutschland einmal für die rohstoffe
aber auch in der fläche die wir für uns
in anspruch nehmen das heißt wir haben
ein eigenes interesse daran dort geld
hin zu geben für den schutz dieser
ökosysteme das war die ganze debatte
über den amazonas ein polster nachgesagt
da mache ich platt dann haben wir genau
so ein problem wie er ja wir können
nicht ein drücken wir können wo szenario
der sich in diesen dingen nicht
reinreden lassen will können wir
empfehlen den amazonas nicht weiter
abzuholzen
ich will ehrlich sein und
handelsabkommen nicht wie markus einfach
so unterschreiben sondern da ernsthafte
nachhaltigkeits clausen reingeben
immerhin die supermarktketten aus
england haben sich aufgebaut sondern
sagt wir nehmen euch zeug nicht mehr ab
wenn du nicht aufhörst
natürlich haben wir möglichkeiten
dagegenzuhalten da macht das ja nicht
aus spaß irgendwer muss ihnen das ja
bezahlen was danach an ressourcen im
weltmarkt verkauft wird
da sind wir doch alle mai also das liegt
es nicht daran dass wir nicht wissen was
wir tun sollten sondern dass wir es
nicht tun
ja wir brauchen einfach den politischen
mut zu sagen wie es braucht nun wirklich
ganz andere form der internationalen
zusammenarbeit und kooperation die sich
darauf fokussiert wie schaffen wir das
die un dekade der regeneration
restauration der ökosysteme ist jetzt
gerade angebrochen welche form der
internationalen zusammenarbeit aber auch
welche anpassungen meinetwegen der
europäischen agrarpolitik etc
brauchen wir damit das wachstum endlich
wieder da stattfinden kann
wo die ressourcen für uns an gelandet
sind im wahrsten sinne von land sie
beschreiben in ihrem buch habe ich eben
gesagt so einer tour durisol also einen
überblick über all das was geschehen ist
und was passiert und wie man das ändern
könnte
sie haben zwei töchter sind sie
einigermaßen zuversichtlich dass die in
einer welt aufwachsen in der es besser
wird was die ökologie und ökonomie in
ihrer vereinbarung betrifft
na ja also ich finde wenn man so die
fahrt abhängigkeiten sich anschaut und
wie es gerade läuft dann ist es eher so
der pessimismus des intellekts und der
optimismus des willens aber das was mir
am haben sich viel mut macht im moment
ist ja auch was ich an e mails bekommen
jeden tag auf das buch hin wie viele
menschen sagen wir sehen dass wir was
wirklich anders machen müssen wir wollen
beitragen ich mache jetzt dieses ich
machen und wirklich außerhalb der
typisch verdächtigen
das kommt von den konservativen
unternehmer das kommt von den
ingenieuren das kommen von denen die das
bildungssystem revolutionieren wollen
deshalb ich glaube wirklich wir sind an
einem kipp punkt nicht nur dass wir uns
bei den ökosystemen dem nähern sondern
der soziale kitt punkt wo so
offensichtlich auf dem tisch liegt dass
das was wir bisher gemacht haben nicht
das szenario ist was zukunft gut
aussehen lässt also jede studie wo
nachhaltigkeit irgendeine rolle spielt
sagt ja business as usual ist leider das
szenario was keine gute zukunft
verspricht und trotzdem müssen sich alle
alternativen immer rechtfertigen die
business as usual verändern
köln auf den indikatoren die uns in
diese welt risikogesellschaft rhein
gefahren haben und das ist ja die
einladung aus der wissenschaft sagen hey
wenn wir die indikatoren ändern wenn wir
big data für benutzen und nicht nur geld
messen sondern sagen wir gucken jetzt
wirklich rein wie die ökosysteme
funktionieren
wir fangen jetzt wirklich an
regeneration in unseren tätigkeiten
es braucht ein bisschen 79 jahre bis ich
dann die kreislauf wieder aufgebaut
haben
aber dafür können wir diese neuen
techniken ja wirklich nutzen
wir können auch überlegen wie wir dann
eben soziale gerechtigkeit und soziale
prozesse auch ein stück weit anders
kalibrieren
also wir jetzt ist das jahrhundert wo
wir ganz andere indikatoren brauchen die
sich aus der sozialwissenschaften aus
der naturwissenschaft speisen und nicht
nur in diesem abstraktum der monetären
werte ohne dass irgendwer sich dafür
rechtfertigt was ist meine bewertung da
drin gewesen
was ist der preis den ich drauf geklebt
habe dafür dass diese ganzen bäume
zerstört werden dürfen wie viel sage ich
darf es kosten menschenleben zu retten
warum dürfen große ernährungs konzerne
weiterhin systematisch lebensmittel in
den markt drücken wo zu viel zucker zu
viel fett drin ist warum schreien wir
weiter das fleisch so billig sein muss
selbst wenn alle doppelt so viel fleisch
essen wie es für unsere gesundheit gut
wer und warum ist ein verbot wenn wir
sagen wir möchten die gesundheitskosten
für die gesamte gesellschaft reduzieren
wir möchten menschen eine gesunde
ernährung also da müssen wir noch mal
auf und das ist ja auch die
aufklärerische seite dass er ich freue
mich so wahnsinnig dass die rückmeldung
aus dem konservativen liberalen lager
kommt und das ist ja eine externe also
das war meine umwelt frage und dann war
das irgendwie so parteipolitisch sehr
geparkt auf einer seite und für mich ist
das die ganz große hoffnung gutes
unternehmertum möchte klar sehen ob ich
ökonomisch oder unökonomisch
wirtschaftlich zukünftig risiken habe
oder nicht
eine liberale gesellschaft die sich der
aufklärung oder freiheit verschrieben
hat muss doch auch verantwortung dafür
übernehmen was die konsequenzen meiner
entscheidung sind und der wissensstand
ist so klar heute dass ich nicht einfach
nur schreien kann ihr wollten etwas
verbieten
der wissensstand ist sicherlich wenn man
sich ihren thesen annähert nachdem
lesen ihres buches sehr viel höher das
ist keine frage
trotzdem reden wir oder haben sie jetzt
gerade geredet über politisch
verantwortliche unternehmerisch
verantwortlich
wenn wir aber zum beispiel den
fleischskandal sehen dann werden wir
möglicherweise schon bald wieder die
ganz billige packung von gehackten im
supermarkt sehen und die leute schauen
auch da wieder auf den preis als es
liegt auch an jedem einzelnen genau
aber wir haben ja mehrere wochen in der
gesellschaft also ich kann ja erstmal
anfangen überhaupt darüber zu sprechen
zu sagen oh ja habe ich eingesehen ist
nicht gut und bei meiningen wird es
heute am budget schwierig sein
ökologische lebensmittel einzukaufen
weil das einfach mit hartz4 und
herausforderungen wird ich kann mich
aber gleichzeitig politisch einbringen
und dann sagen ich nehme jetzt meine
stimme als bürgerinnen bürger und mische
mich eine sache möchten die
rahmenbedingungen verändern weil dann
werden nachhaltige lebensmittel zum
standard irgendwann anstatt dafür diese
form von produktion noch weiter
tolerieren
und wenn dann die preise steigen wird
auch die berechnung für den
hartz-iv-satz steigen oder wir sagen hey
passt doch endlich mal die mindestlöhne
an gibt es viele gründe für inklusive
dass menschen sich eine rente leisten
sollten
und deutschland bei der oecd nicht
hinterherkommt mit der anpassung dann
können menschen aus diesem
haushaltsbudget auch nachhaltige
produkte kaufen und deshalb ist ja die
ganze einladung im buch nicht immer nur
nach einer silva bulle zu suchen nach
einem mechanismus sondern wirklich
system ist oder nachzudenken wenn ein
problem da ist was sind die treiber und
was sind die konsequenzen und an welchen
punkten kann ich überall intervenieren
und wir wollen die aufwärtsspirale dann
müssten eigentlich alle menschen diesen
blick diesen earthrise blick sehen auf
die erde und begreifen das ist die
einzige die wir haben das sagen die
astronauten ja auch selber immer wieder
ihnen ist das auch mal diesem augenblick
besonders klar geworden als sie auf die
erde geblickt haben aber ich muss einen
begriff von ihnen noch einmal aufnehmen
nämlich den fiesen montag
die frage ist nämlich sie beschreiben
den fiesen montag als den tag an dem man
mit tollen gedanken aus dem wochenende
montags wieder zur arbeit geht
man hat fantastische vorstellung
kreative gedanken und dann kommt man in
ein büro und in
der organisation und merkt auch das
lässt sich gar nicht so durchsetzen und
ist frustriert ist das der erste schritt
und im zweifel auch nach dem was wir
jetzt gesprochen haben und nach corona
der zweite schritt der dienstag an dem
man diese ambitionen alle wieder
verloren hat und aufgibt vergessen hat
möglicherweise nein aber in dem buch
richter vorgeschrieben hat das ist ja
mehr wissenschaftlich gewesen habe ich
das den radikalen instrumentalist muss
genannte inklusion wie die drei männer
aber da ging es nämlich auch darum auch
in dem buch ist sie vielleicht
aufgefallen dass ich versucht habe die
extrempositionen die immer gegeneinander
in stellung gebracht werden mal so ein
bisschen aufzudröseln und das gibt es in
der forschung auch entweder - radikalen
wandel form fordern oder eben so ein
bisschen reformen und die einen sagen
reform kommen wir nie dahin und die
anderen sagen radikalinskis wollen ja
gleich kommunismus oder so na ja sie
sind ja auch immer wieder beschimpft
worden als öko nazi und da habe ich
lange nicht mehr
aber es geht auch einfach darum wenn wir
auf die muster schauen wie wir heute
haben zum beispiel marktwirtschaft in
vielen bereichen weit davon entfernt und
dann wird immer noch für den freien
markt argumentiert und eigentlich eine
oligopolistische strukturen wo einzelne
konzerne wirklich so eine macht gewonnen
haben dass damit angebot und nachfrage
und mit freie vertragsbindung zwischen
gleichen und so was all das was dieser
grundlage eines einer unsichtbaren hand
im markt der zu grunde liegt gar nicht
mehr gegeben ist
und genau deshalb ist die diese radikale
vision wie es anders gehen kann mit den
vielen kleinen schritten die wir auf dem
weg dahin brauchen das was wir
verheiraten sollten
und dann heißt das ich bemühe mich jeden
tag wieder eine neue variante zu finden
und das passiert wenn ich irgendwann
tatsächlich angefangen habe die welt
anders zu sehen
dann komme ich nämlich nicht mehr so
leicht zurück zu dem mir selber schön
reden zu können dass das super ist was
ich mache im moment haben wir ja den
ganz spannende moment ist wir wenn wir
wertkonservativ sein wollen also
wirklich sagen einige werte werden nicht
verraten
man muss sich jetzt sehr schnell
struktur kreativ werden also wirklich
geschäftsmodelle umbauen wirklich eine
andere form des produzieren sind auch
meinen konsum anpassen und was das
phänomen was wir haben ist die arbeiten
sehr strukturkonservativ und werden wer
kreativ mit sich wie unsere werte
eigentlich umformulierung wo wir weg
blenden
wir gucken damit wir das noch
rechtfertigen können aber da glaube ich
einfach in das menschliche potenzial
und da glaube ich als wissenschaftler
muss ich das ja auch daran dass wissen
schaffen natürlich uns in die
möglichkeit versetzt jeden tag ein
bisschen diese kleinen schritte in
richtung der wirklich dann radikal
anderen versionen auch selber beitragen
zu können also dann letztlich doch
optimistisch gibt einen schönen satz von
robert kennedy den sie im buch zitieren
der heißt das bruttoinlandsprodukt misst
alles außer dem was man eben wirklich
lebenswert macht oder ein schöner
schluss hat ganz herzlichen dank dass
sie dabei waren
dankeschön